you are the gentleman that sent me the
email I think what I think the best
thing for me to do for those that
haven't read it just sort of frame it
I'll just read it out loud and then
we'll sort of um go back and forth and
see what we can do to be useful for you
so this is hey Rich I've watched a lot
of your content and while I'm not a deep
follower of the red pill I'm certainly
interested in becoming the most ideal
man I can and I'm glad you support men
uh I found the red pill years ago and
realized how important status and
confidence is for maintaining attraction
I understand hypergamy
um I used to be more naive but I still
get one I just a lot the reason why I'm
requesting a video and by the by the way
guys if you want to request a video
pinned in the top comment of all my
videos there's links to a bunch of stuff
and one there's uh how to request a
specific video on a topic that you want
to talk about this is one uh the reason
why I'm requesting a video is because I
need Clarity on my situation I want to
remain productive and not sulk though my
romantic failures can consume me without
divulging too much I'm 23 a grad student
at a good University uh who in their
free time enjoys hiking photography
travel and biking I have money saved but
my main priority is education not
business as my school is all paid for
since my family is fairly well off I'm
going to enter a career in politics and
or city and environmental planning and I
spent the last year or two gaining
internship experience I'll let you
assess my life based on my socials more
photos of me than the story reels uh you
can see I like to travel so he linked
his um social media media I had a look
at it and I've also verified that the
person behind the caller name is indeed
our friend in the social media because I
really don't like it when people try to
pull fast ones on me and I always try to
verify that
um
four years I've been balancing between
education professional goals trying to
track women I've been looking for a
relationship for years I've been on 20
plus first dates and asked out countless
swimming through apps social media
campus approaches but I've had a really
high rejection rate I know it's my fault
but I don't know what I'm doing wrong
I've kissed a few but I've never been in
a relationship and I am celibate
recently rejected by an attractive woman
I liked after two dates because you put
in quotations no chemistry even though I
thought we're we were compatible a woman
I've stuck up struck up conversation
with and taken out on dates coffee nice
restaurants bookstores beaches Etc have
told me I'm not shy and I like talking
to you I make them laugh and it seems
okay but ends up being rejected uh the
women I've liked come in all body types
tall taller and shorter than me though I
prefer taller different passions my age
to a decade older and verifying life
plans through ideally I would want goal
oriented sorry goal oriented women I
don't want kids I'm 5'6 thinly built
don't lift weights but I do cardio every
week feel frustrated I want Direction
and someone who's successful so I Turn
to You to gain Insight from the road
pill perspective perhaps people in the
comments can share as well
all right well Bob here we are
all right thanks for having me on yeah
and uh thanks for having the balls to do
this because I know this is uh tough and
it's a difficult conversation so I have
no issue keeping you on
um I know who you are and um you know
we're here to sort of get to some
solutions so give me a little bit of
back uh background on you beyond what
you sort of put in that uh email to me
that provides some
I guess I guess frame around your
childhood like um you know what you like
doing for fun what your hobbies were
were you involved in sports like you
know tell me about your teenagers at
least
yeah
um no I haven't been a big Sports guy
um
because I've I just never been that
athletically inclined
um like I've done tennis and uh
I was doing like cross country in in
like junior high but I've never really
been
like done team sports and that's never
been really been my
um Forte I I think that uh
I was fairly shy as a child and even now
like that still has come up with what
people have said that I'm not like super
shy but I've had a lot of social anxiety
so
I've
I've I had friends as a kid but I wasn't
like the most
you know sociable
um popular
guy
um throughout School throughout College
um I didn't really start
dating until I was like 20
20 21
um
so
I was kind of like a late bloomer there
um
my hobbies are pretty much like I've
gotten really into photography I used to
do a lot of writing but that sort of
held by the way aside
um now I'm more into photography uh I
like biking and I want to pick on
mountain biking
um
more actually I've always liked hiking I
actually joined uh hiking Club um in
school and I kind of met people a bit
that way but it didn't work out 100
um
and
yeah I'm just really like I like the
outdoors
um over staying inside even though I'm
not the most extroverted extroverted and
yeah
okay
um you said you you're joined a few
hiking clubs uh did you have a lot of
gals in the hype hiking clubs yeah um
there were a fair amount
um
of girls in the in the club
I asked out uh I uh approached and like
struck up conversation on the second
on the second hike
um
this chick I talked to I'm probably
almost the entire time but
I got her
social and then it just kind of like
fell by the wayside like she didn't
it just well you know just kind of uh it
didn't progress past there did you guys
exchange text like did you go back and
forth did you flirt with her at all did
you ask her out yeah no just just
chatting like in person was like the
most and then when after
um I gave her my social actually yeah
did she engage any of it
okay so let's deal with the in-person
stuff so I think that's a pretty good
example you know you're going out for a
hike you're walking one of the pieces of
advice I give guys is usually on a first
date on a sniff test it's always great
to grab a coffee and go for a stroll for
a bunch of reasons the main one that I
find is you get to check them out right
because you're walking
you're sort of moving it it's the easy
way to sort of uh have a nice
conversation so you're going for a
stroll what do you usually talk about
with these girls you know you're
interested in or you find her attractive
what do you usually talk about whether
yeah so the last day uh we went to this
first day it was pretty wet good we went
to like a nice restaurant
um
I really talk about like
everything honestly like my in our
interests Hobbies
um
pets I said you said our interest hobby
so does that mean that you're talking
about your interests and hobbies like
losers or mine and hers okay so like
it's kind of like a back and forth
um are you trying to match up to and be
like oh you know I like uh you know you
like uh this and I like this you know
sort of thing is that I kind of I've
I've done a lot of like well at least on
the last date that I'm referring to I
did a little like teasing
um
because not negging but like
kind of like banter and like trying to
be flirty
um
and
so that's why I I just wanted to get to
know her so I just we talked about like
what we're interested in what we
like to do for fun we both weren't that
like athletic
um she's in the same school with you
like how did you run no this is this is
a woman I met on on the apps uh okay so
this is a dating app this isn't the
hiking Club no okay yeah I want to go
back to the hype and sort of deal with
the social sort of conversation so
you're taking a stroll there's a there's
a gal you know you Digger Vibe you find
her attractive you know you start
chattering her up how does that usually
go like how do you open or what do you
try to talk about
um I'd probably just commented on like
school things at first and like her
University experience and my University
experience and the conversation I think
if I remember just kind of
um
like went from there
you know um we talked about like
the outdoors like what we like doing
what we
what we found what we find interesting
about like hiking and and um
you know I think with this person I
didn't really like it wasn't as
flirty you know I wasn't doing as much
like T back and forth kind of like the
answer as
as like I would have if because I I
wasn't the thing is like I wasn't
um it's like a dating app it's like more
you know it's not platonic like right
away
but if it's is she asking you questions
at this point you know you're going for
a while for a long walk yeah there are
other people other guys there it wasn't
just me and her I didn't know her other
guys and you were right but I mean we're
going for a stroll and you're having a
conversation does she get to the point
where she's like hey Bob I'm kind of
interested in you know those shoes or
you know I heard that you like this or
like is she asking you questions yeah a
little but what kind of questions are
you asking you
just about my like you know my degree
like what my interests are my passion
what I like to do but she was also kind
of like alternating between me and the
other guys in the group what do you
think she's trying to get to when she's
asking about your degrees and your
passions and your interests and your
hobbies
I mean I think she's trying to get to
know me but I don't
I I could tell it wasn't like it wasn't
romantic it's just
yeah well let me sizing you up right I
mean so if a woman starts asking you
questions that generally means that
she's got a degree of Interest right
otherwise she won't be asking you a
question she'll just move on or she'll
take her attention somewhere else so
there's there's at least a genuine
beginning to it
yeah I mean maybe it wasn't the best
example because I've had other well just
follow me on this yes just follow me on
this so I mean like what I'm talking
about is captivation here right because
you can do anything you want to Woman
except for bore her so so she's trying
to figure out what's what's interesting
about Bob right like what does he like
to do like does he have an interesting
hobby that I might like to partake in
like does he have a boat oh I like guys
with boats maybe we could go boating
sometimes sort of thing like this is
this is usually how women size up guys
in groups especially if they start
asking questions like oh like what do
you like to do in your spare time and if
it's something that's not that
interesting she's gonna have a hard time
continuing the conversation with you
that's that's just really what I'm just
trying to explain to you to sort of get
you some clarity around the Dynamics of
some of these things because I mean you
do have some social awkwardness I think
you mentioned at the beginning too
right yeah yeah have you have you done
anything to try to work on that like you
doing anything to sort of improve your
conversation skills and flow a little
bit better with that
um other than I did to I've been doing
Toastmasters okay
but that's more speeches that's not
really like
that's not really like interacting with
women
well I mean talking to women is like I
mean you could say it's like giving a
speech I mean one of the tenants that
you'll learn from like the red pill
manoswamp is to to just ignore her
beauty right like just treat her like
she's just a person right because guys
can get caught up and stumble over
themselves oh my God she's a nine she's
a 10 I'm talking to this girl she's
actually here with me she's across the
table for me sort of thing and you you
know you can get lost in her beauty and
like one of the core tenants that you
have to learn as a guy is just to ignore
that and just just treat it like anybody
else like even being slightly
disinterested it sounds like you've done
some pickup artist course or something
because you mentioned neg or did you
read that somewhere in a book no I just
read that okay where'd you read that
on online like the red pill okay some
like I mean or something
Reddit okay got it
um yeah so it's just I mean it just
gives me an idea that you that you've
done a little bit of your research on
this you know sort of thing
yeah yeah so as far as the awkwardness
like you said you've done a little bit
of Toastmasters which is more or less
giving speeches and you say it's not the
same thing as talking to girls but I
would argue you could you could treat it
the same way you know you really could
you know if you're not
if you're not looking at her and being
like Oh my God
just you know Starry Eyed like deer on
the headlight sort of thing do you think
that you can get good at that like it's
not that difficult to do you know to be
honest with you just look at a five look
at a 10 treat them like like you can
practice this just by making eye contact
with all women and holding their gaze
you know if there's a beautiful 10 you
know that you see some are just just
look at her and just pretend like she's
a five
yeah I can I've I've done that I mean
I've been able to do it it's just um
I I don't
I don't necessarily know like
I mean I can tell when I'm Big Hawk but
I'm not always awkward like I feel like
you know on the what as I wanted to say
on the last date that I went on
um we talked today was like three hours
and we talked in we went back and forth
the entire time this was the first date
for three hours it was a first date for
three hours at night let me just let me
just come back to that three-hour date
in one second because I think that'll be
important
um I was just scrolling here and you've
got the pictures of your travels and the
pictures of yourself through your
travels I don't see a Social Circle
there's only one picture here with you
and your family sitting down but I don't
see like Social Circle pictures where
you're sitting around with other guys
yeah I don't um I I only have like
individual friends but I don't really
have like a circle honestly
okay
I'm gonna come back to the friendship in
the circle in a second so
tell me about the three hour date how
did that go
um it went pretty well I I feel like I
held conversation well the entire time I
was flirting with her
um I I don't think I mean she said after
the date she's like you're not that shy
um she invited she agreed to excitement
day and we went on that and she rejected
me but um
I
and I think that one I was like I was a
little more you know awkward but I still
don't think I was
I don't I don't think I was like
anything like it's anything terrible
well something was to happen in the
three hours for her to stick around for
that long and agree to a second date
I just think I really was like
vibing with her like I was I was able to
kind of
connect and like
be
Charming I guess and where'd you do the
date
it was at an upscale restaurant
um after dinner was it drinks was it
coffee it was dinner it was um fairly
pricey but it was dinner okay so you
took her out for a fairly pricey dinner
on her first date the second one was it
was a lunch it was more pricey but this
was also pretty uh and then you bought
her lunch on the second date we split oh
you split the bill in a second and then
yes
interesting